I always found it odd that Pam's plaque
just says reception what else would
anyone think her area was when they
walked in the office and why doesn't she
get her name on the plaque this office
gets us in for taking Pam for granted
granted that's the point but it's still
taking her for granted granted question
what kind of bear is best
it's a ridiculous question false black
bear considering Dwight is pretty much
the patron saint of TV sins I think we
have to send Jim for coming at him so
hard here it's mocking someone
relentlessly considered a hilarious
prank or just me and that's a grand
total of lemon no no way that says $11
City zoom enhance well that's just rude
successor e's posters why does this man
have a giant rectangular tumor growing
out of his right leg and why did he
attach a handle to it with the image of
a beloved cartoon duck beloved cartoon
duck is that exactly it ain't Donald or
Daffy is that supposed to be Darkwing
Scrooge Ludwig von Drake Launchpad
McQuack performing unspeakable acts
um intercourse humping burping the worm
in the mole hole seems pretty speakable
to me where's Creed well it's been 20
years since they had their arms wide
open so maybe still in 1999 waiting for
a hug oh you meant the boxer every week
I'm supposed to take four hours into a
quality spa check at the papermill and
of course the one year I blow it off
this happens so that means Creed hasn't
done an equality check at the papermill
for an entire year when he's supposed to
do it weekly
and no one else caught on to this no one
at the paper mill called and asked why
they hadn't had a quality check in the
past 52 weeks even by sitcom standards
this line of dialogue seems ridiculous
maybe the writers room for the office
needs a quality check this puts us at
threat level midnight roll commercials
for season 7 episode 17 I don't have a
headache I'm just preparing there is no
way this super uptight character would
take a potentially unnecessary drug even
if it were a Flintstones vitamin your
client Dunmore high school sent out
their prom invitations on this paper so
they actually had the paper in their
hands to inspect before mailing them and
they'd still be mailed the invitations
wait for them to find out and the story
controls you that's what happened to oj
I'm not sure what to sit in here the
fact they were making oj simpson jokes
in 2007 or the fact that we watching
this in 2019 makes the OJ Simpson joke
relevant again by the way I'm sitting
the only difference between me and a
homeless man is his job and your home I
like ice cream too mate
I need a toss I get that it's the point
but I'm still sending bad Australian
accents it's a laugh like a quarter of
the time
you mean like the show after season five
check out this sunshine man global
warming right climate change discussions
well not everything guys says needs to
be sets Twitter why is my girlfriend
here the one in the green hoodie Wow
well your girlfriend is here because
cringe show gotta cringe but yeah show
sure does go to maximum convenience for
this age of consent sure age of consent
shion's first rule and roadside beat
sales but the most attractive beats on
top using dr. Dre's marketing plan
without getting permission first
are you student yeah oh yeah you never
told me you're in high school
does nard dog want to get caught dating
a minor because this is how you get
caught in are dogging a minor I think he
had hurts or something suburban mom talk
after a screening of motherless Brooklyn
somehow made its way into this script
twelve years before motherless Brooklyn
came out then Newsweek picks it up and
then CNN is a story about it and YouTube
we've been spotted
everyone duck Michael likes me to run
the camera when he makes his apology
videos I hear Pam works for Kevin Hart
now let me tell you something something
from the heart
Michael Nunnally skips the entire first
half of his cue card but completely
changes the line it's Jim Carrey near by
arrow typing new words to his brain why
do bad things always happen to the good
people it's tragic just tragic maybe
wait till you get home to throw the card
away you work in an office with the
white snoop that will be found in the
next 20 minutes mmm it's sweet that Jim
does this and I love the touches of
cinnamon in the office but does every
single episode have to end with one
here's a sin for in another episode
ending with a token tug on the
heartstrings
papercuts now they can be a [ __ ] it
only cost me $7 to recreate the rest of
the ensemble and that's a grand total of
eleven dollar and eleven you always
double down a lot with the image of a
beloved cartoon duck using of the
Rogaine Jack the prime minister of
Sweden visited Washington today and my
tiny little nipples went to France